after a critic slam dr anthony fauci for
saying it's too soon to tell if
americans can gather for christmas well
he's now walking it back what
that was misinterpreted i will be
spending christmas with my family i
encourage people particularly the
vaccinated people who are protected to
have a good normal christmas
with your family okay so tyrus is here
to talk about this um
i watched it i don't think it was
misinterpreted he might have answered it
in a way that he didn't want to answer
it but the clear takeaway on sunday was
it's too soon to tell if you can spend
christmas with your family i'm just an
incredibly good-looking wrestler maybe
some people it's really incredible
wrestler but
how do you misinterpret science it's
supposed to be just the facts how did
you misinterpret it you said christmas
was canceled like you took the grinch's
job and now you're walking it back
like we have moved i hate to say but in
my house particularly we've moved on
from fouchy we we realized we're
vaccinated we take precautions we know
there's sharks in the water and we're
careful and i think a lot of americans
are kind of you shouldn't have this kind
of oh i have to re-say that it's science
what do you mean you misinterpreted
science maybe a math problem but you're
telling us straight up there was no
christmas and now you're walking it back
which means makes me feel like you're
not really talking to us about science
and the cdc today they also had guidance
up there about the holidays they took
that down right and they're expected to
revise that so before we get to
christmas though we have columbus day
yes and halloween yep halloween veterans
day veterans day thanksgiving will you
be celebrating all of those thanksgiving
is my favorite holiday it is the one
time i get to let my hair down and just
not worry about calories
you know what
next question please okay next question
is this uh there's a powerball winner
700 million dollars what would you do if
you won the lottery
what would i do have you won life's
lottery yeah i have one life's lottery
uh i have
uh you know 700 million dollars this
would be a very different interview
today i think it could be could you blow
your hair down i'd be i'd probably be in
a bathrobe
you know i just would not be paying
attention you couldn't tell me anything
700 i have 700 million reasons why i'm
late to work today but sometimes people
who win the lottery they don't
necessarily it doesn't all turn out
always turn out great no because you end
up having an um
i'm willing to bet there's going to be a
lot of relatives showing up right how
many best friends just say no you got to
just you know with anything anytime
you're successful people are going to
come knocking at your door long-lost
relatives parents whatever the case may
be with their hands out and as soon as
you start giving it away it'll be gone
you can't let them in you got to stay
with the what got you there stick to
your close friends the people who were
there when you you know when you had
miss meal cramps and we're making
choices between electric bill and going
to the club those are the ones you keep
with you not the ones that are going to
show up because
he or she is going to be very popular do
you play the lottery no i no my life's
the lottery
you won the lottery yes as of right now
all right trace are you there to weigh
in on this
i'm here if i had 7 million 100 million
dollars that you're asking is that the
question of the day i would buy me i'd
do this with a song said i'd buy me a
boat and a truck to pull it what would
you call it
uh
i shoot what would i call this a good
question that's a great question
you didn't ask me that i would have i
would have a truck boat truck i would
have a truck and a boat pulling a
smaller truck and it'd be the ss i made
it
and he did i mean he always always makes
it it's only 699 million dollars i mean
i said 700 million dollars i don't want
to what's a decimal point right i don't
know we could ask your daughter because
tyrus last week uh tracy he didn't come
to a dinner in nashville because he was
there to take care of his daughter who
had a
math test
and she passed she only missed one she
missed one time
both girl dads bless your heart tyres
you're a good man you're a good dad and
good father i mean that's gonna be great
stuff i'll tell you though that gets it
gets tougher as they get older just
remember that it's tough now
it's tough now it's tough now indeed all
right trace thank you tyrus thank you